in this video we'll talk about wholesale
patch clamp recording technique
wholesale patch clamp is one type of
configuration used in the patch clamp
technique overall this technique is used
to determine the electrophysiological
properties of neuron
in this video we'll talk about what is
wholesale configuration
the working principle application and
how to interpret the data
let's get a quick overview of patch
clamp
technique patch clamp method allows the
investigation of small set of or even
single ion channel properties
patch clamp experiments can be done
either on dissociated culture or
neuronal cultures
if we look at the applications of patch
clamp we'll see that investigations of
ion channels can be done using this
technique
especially it is important for excitable
cells like neurons or other cells like
cardiomyocytes
important method in
uh medical research is patch clamp
because
this particular technique can be used to
detect iron channel properties and many
diseases are associated with ion channel
from a pharmacological point of view
this is also interest for interesting
for screening drugs which act on ion
channel
and patch clamp recordings can also be
combined with live cell imaging which is
really useful for the neuroscientists
so many properties of neuron can be
determined using this wholesale patch
clamp recording
such as the capacitance conductance
firing frequency input resistance firing
pattern etc
so bunch of electrophysiological
parameters can be determined
so let's look at the patch clamp
recording setup to understand this
process better so this is how the
electrophysiology rig would look like
here you can see the microscope with
micro manipulators attached we'll look
at it in bit more details later on
then it entire setup is kept in a
faraday cage
and the microscope is mounted on a
vibration free table because
getting the neuron patched is really
difficult job and no vibration should be
there while recording this stuff
then there is amplifiers oscillators etc
and everything is connected with a
software in a computer
and there is also a sample preparation
table where one can breville electrodes
one can prepare their tissue sample etc
so this is our overall patch setup look
like
now if we look at the
micro manipulator we can see a electrode
it is attached with the micro
manipulator
so this allows maneuvering of the
electrode
around the neuron and with the objective
we can image
the particular neuron that from where we
want to patch so it will allow us to do
the visualization part
so in this setup we can see the
customize stage looks like this
and the samples are prepared in a acsf
or artificial cerebrospinal fluid such
that they're alive or otherwise they
won't show any kind of
electrophysiological properties
then this is the micro manipulator with
which the electrodes are attached
and here you can see the microscope
objective
now let's see how we can use patch clamp
wholesale recording configuration
to determine several
electrophysiological properties first of
all it can be used to determine action
potentials like shown here
so
here is the electrode and here is the
small patch of neuronal membrane as seen
in this diagram
so patching a neuron is difficult first
of all a suction is applied to aid this
particular membrane seal and this
membrane seal is so tight that the
resistant reach giga ohm range that's a
lot
and this tight seal isolates the
membrane electrically
whatever ion flows through these ion
channels in this patch of membrane
now can be detected by the amplifiers
attached with these electrodes
so moral of the story the seal has to be
very tight such that nothing can leak
out
so let's talk about some technical
details of wholesale patch clamp
technique
so
here this is the patched membrane this
is the electrode this is the pipette
solution
first of all the glass pipette isolates
the portion of the membrane when you
patch on the neuron
and it is connected to an amplifier like
this
and this amplifiers amplify the
miniature currents or voltage changes
otherwise it's impossible to detect
so the amplifiers are really important
setup in wholesale configuration or any
kind of patch clamp configuration
now let's talk about that subtypes of
patch clamp there are several sub types
of patch clamp
we call it configurations such as cell
attached configuration wholesale
configuration inside out and outside out
configuration
this video is dedicated about the whole
cell configuration so wholesale is one
type and one configuration of a patch
clamp recording method
so question is how wholesale
configuration is achieved so this is a
portion of the neuronal membrane and
here is the searching electrode this
phase is known as the search a positive
pressure is applied through this
electrode such that the tip of the
electrode remains very clean
here if we inject a voltage we would see
a current like this
now whenever we patch onto a neuron like
this and establish a giga ohm seal then
the resistance would increase so high
that we would see almost no current like
this
this indicates that we have established
a giga ohm seal
once we have established a giga ohm seal
then suction is applied to break open
this connection
and then a rapid current flows like this
you can see in red
that means the whole cell configuration
is established
now patch clamp wholesale configuration
has two operation regimes
one is voltage clamp mode and another is
current clamp mode
so in the voltage clamp mode the voltage
remains constant and we measure current
so here we inject some kind of stimulus
and we see
the response and you can see the
response in
pico amps that means it is current that
we are measuring so voltage clamp
measures current
and in current clamp method we clamp the
particular
current and measured the voltage change
so here we can see the voltage has
changed looking at the axis it is
completely understandable here you can
see the axis levels as millivolt and
millisecond so change in voltage is
determined so if you want to record
action potentials collet current clamp
method is the correct option
now here we can see automated simulation
of a wholesale configuration current
clamp recording with the increase of
current step we can see how the voltage
is changing and giving rise to action
potential and in the side by side we can
see this in a voltage versus current
graph
so you see when the
current is becoming more and more there
is an increase in voltage and suddenly
there is a action potential
now let's try to contextualize this from
a known example let us look at the
glutamatergic synapse in the
glutamatergic synapse we would find
glutamate receptors such as ampa
receptors which binds to glutamate and
allows cations to
get in
and there is nmda receptors which is
also bound to
which is which is also bound to
glutamate but doesn't allow
ions to get in until and unless the
inside is really really positive
so after conduction via ampa receptors
the inside becomes positive
and the nmd receptors becomes conductive
because the magnesium ion is now
repelled by this excess positive charge
inside
so in order to understand the current
properties of ampa and nmda receptor we
can perform this whole cell recording
method
so let us look at the
electrophysiological properties of ampa
receptor
so in this case we can do a voltage
clamp recording that means we are
clamping voltage recording current we
can hold the cell in minus 70 millivolts
minus 50 millivolts and record the
current like this
in order to interpret this data in a
better fashion we plot a iv curve iv
curve means voltage versus
voltage versus current plot
here you can see from this iv plot that
inward current flows in negative voltage
whereas outward current flows in
positive voltage and 0 is the reversal
potential
similarly we can look at the properties
of nmda receptor using similar methods
we can inject negative current
we can hold the voltage at a negative
potential like minus 70 minus 50
and we can measure the current like this
also we can plot this in an iv plot as
you can see here
in the iv plot we can see almost no
current at the negative voltage whereas
little amount of inward current
in the
voltage which is minus 50 or beyond or
close to zero that means slightly more
positive
and we can see outward current in a
positive voltage
so this is how we can understand the
properties of nmda and ampa mediated
currents
we can compare these currents using
these iv plot so for electrophysiologist
this iv plot is super duper useful
so let me tell you how this is useful
let's say one electrophysiologist
exclusively want to record amper current
and want to get rid of the nmda current
knowing these iv plot would allow them
to do so let me tell you how
so let us consider two voltages
so
at plus 60 millivolt voltage if we
record we would see both amp and nmda
current
amper current is in blue and nmda
current is in red but if we do
hold the cell in minus 660 millivolt
then we see there is an amper current
but no nmda current and this can be
nicely visualized from the iv plot
due to the magnesium block no current
flows in the negative voltage so if we
hold the cell in a negative voltage we
can isolate the ampa currents from a
pool of ampa and nmdm mediated currents
so these kind of nitty gritty details
are used by the electrophysiologist to
get a better sense about the
electrophysiological properties of the
neuron
so in summary what we looked at
is initially there is a
attachment to the cell in a whole cell
configuration very similar to the cell
attached
recording and then there is a breakage
of the membrane which allows the
interior of the cell to become
continuous with the solution in the
pipette
and it is very useful to determine the
overall properties of the neuron so i
hope this was useful you can get many
flash cards and notes associate with
these videos and other videos in my
facebook page you can follow my
instagram page for daily updates all the
links are in description in order to
support my channel you can click on the
super thanks option which is present in
the bottom right corner of any video you
can contribute using paytm paypal or upi
you can support my channel
by subscribing to it you can also
subscribe the nerd medic channel for
exclusive medical content see you in
next video